we're at a moment of real flux in this
because when I wrote the book the
abstinence teacher I wrote it as a kind
of reaction to the 2004 election and to
that sense I had at that point there's
just this yawning cultural divide
between the blue states in the red
states and that we're living in two
entirely separate realities and what I
wanted to do is try and get those two
realities into one town so create a kind
of microcosm of the culture work by the
time the book came out in 2007 I don't
think I was alone in feeling like the
culture war had sort of died down
there'd been that watershed election in
2006 were the Democrats had kind of
taken over the house you know Bush had
gotten so mired in the debacle of Iraq
that his social agenda kind of fell
apart that also been a series of
scandals involving you know the Reverend
Ted Haggard Mark Foley all these sort of
guardians of morality on the right and
once again exposed themselves as you
know hypocrites to some degree or other
but by the time then a year went by
McCain is running he's running as the
one Republican who didn't seem to have a
very strong cultural and social social
conservative agenda but then he picked
Sarah Palin to be his running mate and
you could just see that that sort of
latent culture war just flared back up
it was just right in front of us and
they're all these through angry social
conservatives who just have been deeply
frustrated because they'd been
marginalized in the Republican primaries
but in that period between around 2007
there was this real sense that the
monolithic voice of the evangelical
right had started to break down you know
kids if like these liberal Christians
who had been hiding for years just
suddenly came out and said hey wait a
minute you know Jesus wasn't just
talking about sexual morality Jesus was
talking about poverty Jesus was talking
about being stewards of the earth you
know and there was it and I think that's
still going on i think i think that the
angelical right doesn't have the clout
that it used to have but we'd be wrong
to think that it just went away it's
there but it's not going to dominate the
Republican Party for what the way it did
in the sort of Karl Rove George Bush
manner and and one thing that happened
as a result of writing this book was I
heard I got emails from from a lot of
Christians but in a way it's not
surprising there were liberal Christians
who I think were sympathetic to a way
that I wrote about the character Tim who
is a guy who is in a sense been saved by
religion but is struggling to really
figure out how he can live his life in a
Christian weight so it's not you know he
it's it's hard and it's a struggle and
certain things make sense to him in
certain things don't me he's he's a kind
of searching Christian figure and and I
didn't get a whole lot of flack from the
far right cause I just don't think they
read novels and they just don't think
they read novels like this for sure but
I did get a lot of really interesting
responses from liberal Christians who I
think felt like like a lot of the book
rang true to people that they'd known
and struggles that they'd had with
you're trying to live a Christian life
but also you know have a kind of more
flexible or tolerant set of moral
standards particularly around sexual
issues